[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je t'aime comme
halo bon ok vas-y ce soir on sort mais
on repart a promis ça j'ai
l'idée de gym et de
sa rigueur l'a trahi
et oui c'est pas que je suis plus moi
j'ai deux teintes acidulées
rens
bonjour isabelle
pouvoir enlever les masques aujourd'hui
si je commence
bel orgue la main vous fait une drôle de
tête je trouve son rhume même le long du
visage a changé c'est vrai je suis un
homme j'ai un pénis
[Applaudissements]
puisque madore harry potter qui est mon
mec
ah non à
qui est ma meilleure amie où on met
la meuf est tout le temps aux sanitaires
en feat ça veut dire que dès que j'ai un
problème sanitaire qui est mon pire
ennemi est ravie ennemis bah ouais nommé
évidemment déjà quelqu'un qui porte des
tailleurs rose comme ça tout le temps
mauvais signe qu'ils aiment maman ou mon
amante fons mappus dis moi tu ou
[Musique]
non
il était la trace d'un monde révolu
[Rires]
qui dit à ton père disparu